this is for you tori but also maybe for
you jenny i mean
real housewives of beverly hills there
were rumors that you and your mom would
do it
would you go from beverly hills 90210 to
the real housewives
of beverly hills there's rumors every
single season i don't even know where
they come
from uh like i've always said i'm a huge
fan jen knows i'm a huge fan
she doesn't watch housewives like i
watch all the housewives
i love it it's my it's my
entertainment you know it's we work hard
we mom hard
and at the end of the night i'm like i'm
putting my housewives on
yes um no clue where it came from
what what would it take for you to sign
on to a show
like that or that show is she i don't
think she'd let me
you know then he would let you come up
to me
we have like so many projects that we
want to
do on camera and off camera because
we're really really good producing
partners as well
so we have so many exciting things lined
up
um that all stick to being a viewer okay
jenny does that mean that you would
never consider doing it either
no i that's not my jam not your jam
what what other projects are you guys
working on there's so many sometimes i
forget
the list um
yeah we have i don't know if i can even
talk about that one
but we have a christmas movie that we
are
ready to go into production on we have
uh what else
a show of what a show about
yeah that one i don't know if i can say
it though we love to create
and we love to give you know the
unexpected to people
in all forms um so we have a lot of
things and a lot of things coming out
that people probably
wouldn't expect that we would be
venturing into
okay this christmas movie will you guys
co-star in it together are you guys
producing it only
both we created it we're producing it
and starring it
actually we have writers that um we all
really collaborated a lot but we do have
really
brilliant writers that work on it okay
but we created the story the four of us
did
our writing team i love a holiday movie
it's the same same creators that we
created bh 90210
with i love working with them bh 90210 i
mean i could not get enough of it
and when it ended of course i was one of
the
millions who was like please can we get
a season two he wasn't so sure about a
season two like
is there any sort of hope that you can
give to fans that
that would come back in some capacity i
loved
creating that show and making that
happen and doing it i can't believe
we got it done but we did and
we moved
yeah we were told like getting the whole
cast back together
that's the impossible but we kind of
like being challenged with the
impossible because it makes us
really our drive like go even harder
so etc um
shannon doherty recently and she said
that she did have hesitations about
doing it
did either of you ever have any sort of
hesitation about doing it just because
of how iconic the original was
every day really
you had to talk me off the cliff so many
times
so obviously we wanted to do it but yeah
yeah there were no
you didn't okay there were definitely
moments where i was like i don't know if
this is a good idea
and i was like this is a great idea yeah
it was
but that's very much our friendship
the two of you like talking each other
down and then always
thank god yeah first of all this new
podcast
idea is so exciting why should fans tune
in to the premiere episode
on november 9th
because they never know what we're gonna
say
we never know what we're going to say
but it's always going to be fun it will
be a fun ride for sure
you